[Music]
Christian
l
[Music]
Christian
allor right bu
[Music]
hello
everyone can I tell you a secret you
know what the worship team doesn't tell
you when you stand up here you get to
see everybody's Happy Shiny faces and
it's so wonderful so thank you for
coming tonight also hello our online
friends I can't see your faces but I'm
sure they are happy and Shining as well
um so couple of things really just one
big thing announcements there is a chili
cook off tonight so the fellowship hall
or multi-purpose building whatever we
call that out the back door tonight
after service um we will have our chili
cook off to celebrate the table's fifth
birthday so um please feel free to join
us there's already a ton of chili and
sides out there if you did not bring
anything do not let that stand in your
way of partaking in the cornicopia of
chili that is out there um please I'm
sure none of us want to take any home
um so that's the big announcement for
today after that um we've lit some
candles for
um I put it away and I wasn't done
reading
um to represent the sign and presence of
Christ Among Us fully Divine and fully
human
so as we exit the kingdom of noise hurry
and
productivity now we enter the kingdom of
Silence Stillness and simplicity a
Sacred Space a place for prayer worship
and adoration a place to behold Christ
revelation of God heartbeat of creation
allow The unforced rhythms of Grace to
find you to mend your heart and we all
come
home thank you Jared you go ahead and to
your feet we're going to get started
jump in here
worship and uh one of the bright spots
that for me anyways and showing up on
Sundays is just looking out into your
faces and remembering that we're all in
this together and um sometimes even
though the week leading up to this has
been rough you know sometimes there's a
lot of emotion going on or you know
busyness um heartbreak whatever it is
that brings us to this moment when I get
here there's just that sense of this is
this is where I want to be where you can
take a breath where you can settle
yourself ground into the presence of God
and into the
community um so I just invite you into
that space with us
[Music]
let's sing
no
there's here in love in love no place I
would ra be no place I would rather
be no place I would rather be here in
your love in your
[Music]
love let's sing that again together new
place there's no place i' ra
be no place i' ra
be no place i' Rather Be Here In Your
Love Here In Your Love
no place i' Rather
Be No Place i' Rather
Be No place I'd ra be here in your love
Here In Your
Love set a fire down in my soul that I
can't contain that I can't control I
want more of you God I want more of you
God set of fire down in my soul that I
can't contain that I can't control I
want more of you God I want more of you
[Applause]
God no place i' Rather
Be No Place rather be there no place
that i' rather
be no place that i' rather be than Here
In Your Love Here In Your Love No Place
i' would ra
be no place I would
[Music]
ra i' ra be here in your love Here In
Your
Love set a fire down in my soul that I
can't contain
that I can't control I want more of you
God I want more of you God set a fire
down in my soul that I can't contain
that I can't control I want more of you
God I want more of you
God more of you
let's sing I want
more I want more I want more I want more
I want more I want
[Music]
more to pour it
out I want more I want more I want more
I want more I want more I want more
so pour it
[Music]
out so come and consume God all we are
give you permission our hearts are yours
we want
you we want
you come and consume God all we are give
you permission our hearts are yours we
want
you we want you we want you so come and
consume God all we are we give you
permission our hearts are yours we want
you I want more of you we want you we
want you
come and cons all we are give you
permission our hearts are yours we want
you I want more you want you we love
you we love
you and we'll never stop can't live
without you Jesus
we love
you we can't get enough enough all this
is for
you
Jesus we love
you will never
stop
without love
Jesus no I love you
no never
stop all this is
[Music]
for down soul that
I that I came control I want more of you
God I want more of you
God all right kiddos know the drill
they're headed to their classes we love
you guys yall have
fun in Romans 5 it
says but we also rejoice in our
sufferings because we know that
suffering produces
perseverance and perseverance character
and character hope and hope does not
disappoint
us because God has poured out his love
into our hearts by the Holy Spirit whom
he has given us
[Music]
we have suffered all kinds of
grief tasted the bitter cup of
defe out of the bitter come something
sweet our faith more precious than
gold we have been tested by so many
fires burned in the heat of what our
faith
requires find us here singing in a
foolish our faith more precious than
gold our faith our faith more precious
than gold though we don't see
you though we don't see you we love
you when we don't fear you we still
sing we've got a reason to trust
you Jesus in
[Music]
Everything Jesus
in there's a secret there is a secret we
can
[Music]
only walk in through places we don't
want to
go in the we learn the song
of our fith more precious than
gold our fith more
preious though we don't
see though we don't see you we love
you but we don't feel you we still see
we've got a reason to trust
you Jesus in Everything Jesus in
Everything Jesus in
everything tears tears on the
altar from all we
li following you no matter what it
cost maybe you
whisper Maybe
Ro this is the sound of those who love
you Lord this is the sound to those who
love let's sing that again tears tears
on
thear from all we
lost following you no matter what it
cost maybe a
wish
maybe this is the sound of those Love
You Lord this is the sound of those who
love you
Lord though we don't see you we love
you then we don't feel you we still
s we've got reason to trust
you Jesus in
everything sing
Jesus Jesus in every one more time
Jesus Jesus in
everything Tears On The
Altar from all we
lost following you no matter what it
cost maybe you
whisper maybe you Ro this the sound of
those who love you Lord Tears On The
Altar tears the
altar from all we
lost you no matter what it
cost maybe a
whisper maybe a roar this is the sound
of those who love you Lord this is the
sound of those who love you Lord this
this is the sound of those who love you
Lord this is the sound of those who love
you Lord tears on the
alt all
lost following you no matter what it
cost May
whisper maybe you're WR this the sound
of those who love you Lord this is the
sound of those to Love You Lord this is
the sound of those who love you
Lord so sweet to trust in
Jesus to take him at his
word just to
rest upon and his
[Music]
prise just to
know the say the
Lord
Jesus
Jesus how I trust him how I
prove him
more Jes Jesus
Jesus
preious
Jesus Oh for Grace to trust him
[Music]
more
you I'm so glad iar learn to trust him
Precious
Jesus
Savior
friend and I know that thou are with me
will be with me to the
end Jes Jus
Jesus how I trust him how
I him more
and
Jesus
preious
Jesus Oh for Grace to
trust sing that again Jesus
Jesus how I trust him how I prove him
for
and
Jesus
preious
Jesus Oh for Grace to
trust
[Music]
more Jesus
Jesus
preious
Jesus Oh
for to trust
him God I look back on these last five
years and I can remember so many moments
where we have had to trust you
where we've had to dig in
deep and every time God you are
faithful you continue to build your
church by
Grace by
goodness by faithful people who show up
and lay down their lives
and serve
[Music]
others God and not just as a community
but as individuals we walk through hard
times we've seen our share of troubles
and pain and suffering but you remain
good you remain
enough and over and over and over would
we continue to trust you with our lives
with our families with our
relationships would we trust you with
this
church with our city and our
country would we continue to believe
that you are doing a good
work and you don't give up on the work
of your
hand you see it through to
completion so God give us your eyes to
see give us vision for your
heart give us
patience and
perseverance because we know in those
things you produce character you produce
hope and we need your hope God
and we're so grateful for
it continue to do your work in our
hearts and in our lives and help us to
keep showing up God and trusting you
with the
rest in Jesus name
amen would you guys go ahead and greet
the people that are around you
B
not
wcy Beed here that's what f
[Music]
ring the
bells ring the
bells your tiny people you
beening
statues to
thunder breaking through
[Music]
bell
bell I only was in the room of Kingdom
where I I Bel I ain't scared to face a
foress I have seen fall with broken
bones you built
itum
[Music]
by ring the
bells ring the bells
ring the
bells ring the
bells
Bell
Rell Bells timean it
[Applause]
woohoo we made it five years it's good
it's good yeah give another
hand yeah just really really grateful
grateful for who this community is uh
grateful to to be together and to be
making this journey together so uh my
name is Brett and the pastor here
pronounce he him and it's uh a joy a joy
to be with you and also want to welcome
those joining us online love youall lots
and um yeah and also anyone here tonight
who is new thank you for for being Among
Us so obviously uh you all have come on
a very special night as we're
celebrating the the fifth anniversary of
the table and uh we thought as we were
kind of processing as an elder team we
thought you know what better way to
celebrate than to hear some stories of
uh folks in their own journeys of growth
and transformation and falling in more
in love with God and just all that and
so uh that's what we're going to do
tonight now of course it would be ideal
if like we could hear from everyone uh
but that's not realistic so we have
asked a few people to uh to come on up
and share so that in mind I want to
invite up Kaylee and Landon fiser y'all
give them a hand as they come on up
[Applause]
so no this is the the microphone's not
your thing well it is now my
friend so uh fishes I wondered could you
all start by sharing a little bit of
like background you know it's like you
got kiddos and uh even just a little bit
of your like your own kind of formative
ears and what that all kind of looked
like
watch
of
you're kind of formative years
and
years
so you so you're there kind of you're
kind of coming from that more large mega
church you know kind of typical around
here kind of background you're having a
little bit different you kind of found
your way into kind of the Evangelical
world but didn't necessar always align
with that since you weren't like raised
in it like steeped in it you know yeah
um and then
you know you're at the table now so kind
of what was I don't know if you would
call it deconstruction or use that word
you know but what was that Journey kind
of out of that world like for you what
what spurred that on what's the
experience you know kind of been like
for you in
that mine's probably easier than yours
um for me because we were moving away I
just we were removed from that um and so
we went from Rockwell to College Station
for a year and it was just really easy
for me to be like you know what actually
I don't work here anymore we're not
involved here anymore this is actually
what I truly believe um and that's kind
of where I was yeah I didn't really have
much of a deconstruction necessarily as
much as a um just wanting to fully
remove myself from from something that I
didn't fully align myself with I'm also
working through a lot of um not anger
but just trying to heal from from that
from resentment that's yes yeah yeah
so yeah um wow it's loud figure that
yeah farther away from the math um I
definitely did have some sort of uh long
uh and potentially ongoing sort of
deconstruction phase where so I I went
to college down at Tex A&M and and um
the the group of friends that I got
plugged in with just kind of randomly
was two or three missionary kids from
Eastern Europe who were and still are
very theologically conservative even
socially conservative but also just had
none of the like social cultural baggage
with Christian faith that I did so me
being the me that I was in
2012 thank you
um I was I was uh like I said very
outspoken and loud and Brash and they
were very gracious with me to be like
hey what's the deal with that because
that's pretty
weird without going into specifics but
it kind of prompted me to to start
reexamining some of those things and
also just you know the the freedom of
being in a new place with not without
family close by and and another good
friend that I had made at the same time
was sort of going through the same thing
and she was from the the panhandle of
Texas sort of similar background
otherwise but was was going through a
lot of the same thoughts that I was at
the time and so she and I had started
kind of figuring out where do we feel
like we fit in uh what do we think we
believe and um it it sort of was a
spiraling process um of a lot of
figuring out what I didn't um and well I
guess that is ex what deconstruction is
but just like but that all happen very
quickly like the all of the the walls
fell very fast um and other than briefly
considering becoming Eastern Orthodox of
all
things
um yeah uh other than that there wasn't
really like any sort of Landing place at
all uh and there wouldn't have been
for close to a
decade um because from that point I just
kind of figured out like like well
nothing around me really fits where I
think that I am anymore which was like
dealing with some pretty intense just
doubt in
general um and I just kind of decided
to at least for the time being set that
aside and be okay with that I I was
involved in some Ministries with the
church down there um was specifically
asked not to return to one of them
uh because I couldn't like they had you
know like a statement of faith and such
and I was like I I can't read all of the
lines on this and say
Yes uh and they were like well thanks
for being honest but please don't come
back so from there uh you know we got
married Charlotte came along a year and
a couple months later and um it was just
kind of I just kind of put everything
down for a long time and didn't really
pick it back up or even the thought of
trying to look at it again was really
painful
um yeah I just sort of refused to think
about it more than more than anything
else was those kind of years what was
that like on y'all's relationship you
know was was that kind of a sort
intention or was it kind of bring
together or what what was that
experience
like it's hard to say Landon and I like
when we so we got we started dating and
then within a year we got married and so
was and then we had to move it was just
very fast and furious Charlotte we had
her within our first year of being
married sounds pretty hectic yeah it was
just a lot and so um we're learning how
to be married we're learning how to live
together we're learning how to be
parents we're learning how to survive
financially
when you know resources aren't there and
so it was just it was a lot I don't
there was never where I thought our
marriage
was con like at a concerning point which
I'm thankful for um because I'm I'm glad
we're no matter what we're still that
team um but there was so much missing
and I didn't want to be like a Naggy
person like we should go to church let's
go to church we should go to church
somewhere we have kids now let's go to
church well we we did kind of do that
for a little bit and we tried we tried
to when when he sorry I okay when we
moved when we moved back back home to
rock wall from living in College Station
and having Charlotte we tried to put
ourselves back into where we grew up and
it was even more painfully obvious then
where and like even watch I hope you
don't mind me saying watching like him
and service he he would like his hands
would be like baled up in fist visibly
angry like really upset and I'm like
really in a spirit of worship really
entering in and for me I'm like I'm fine
being here I just want to be
somewhere yeah and it would ruin my
whole weekend yeah so we stopped going
and and another thing I should add going
back to your your last question is um
that same friend that had kind of
explored things with me freshman year um
towards the end of college came out to
me as trans and um if there had been any
like
lingering reticence to to just want to
set all of that aside that was like
final because this is like my best
friend for the last four years um
so at the time I already knew that she
was at least some to some degree gender
non-conforming but when I asked her to
be the best man at our wedding she said
yes
but um that's not that's not actually
what I am um so that was that was really
like the not the nail in the coffin but
um at least the that fork in the road at
the time
yeah how do you think of your journey
now like do you do you think of it kind
of like still kind of in that
deconstruction kind of phase like J I'm
still thinking this through tearing
certain things down just not sure or in
a more kind of rebuilding phase what
what how would you describe kind of
where you are
now um I think in a lot of ways it's
just kind
of picking up I left off a little bit um
which for
me doesn't mean that any of the like
doubt or anything is gone it's it's I
studied philosophy at school and in a
lot of ways it like the writings of saen
kard resonate a lot with me the the
tension of of holding something that on
its face and on examination is
inherently
absurd but but making a choice to be
okay with that and that's kind of still
I think I am and I don't think that
that's something I could ever
necessarily move on from there are
better days and there are worse days as
far as like feeling it and I I don't
even like using that
language um because I mean I was like
the person in high school who like it's
at church camp and everybody's like
really getting into it and this isn't
even like a charismatic church but I'm
just kind of like I I don't get it guys
like I'm not I'm not feeling this
um just but it's not ever where my head
has been so I think it's
just I I I knew and know what I don't
believe and I have a
very a very measured core of what I do
and I'm willing to build on that core
but not um not without doing so very
carefully if that makes
sense Kay how about for you I mean I
know he didn't really go through like an
intense deconstruction but you know so
um but what would well maybe I'll kind
of go to the next question because it
might kind of tie in so what role kind
of has like the table you know kind of
re-engaging church again and how how has
that been and and maybe that ties back
in with the other piece which is you
know just where are you
now so we started we started coming to
the table in March of this year so we
haven't been members for that long but
we feel pretty welcome and a part of the
family now at this point um sorry I'm
trying to bring my thought back to what
I was doing um for me personally I've um
I always say there's comfort in
community and like
mindedness um and so it's it's a place
of like I said it's a place of Peace for
me um and for us as a family and even
like our kids like it's just just
wanting to them somewhere where they
feel safe where they're loved where as
they're growing and and learning about
themselves that they feel like they are
loved care for welcome and kept as an
equal no matter what um and that's the
most important thing for us um yeah and
then for me just trying to I like to I
tend to keep things pretty up here um
Landon likes to De dive deep into the
tissue of things and um I do not and so
that's it's kind of more of my thing
where I'm trying to just create more of
a dee rooted community and so
anyway you what's it been like here um
well I mean you know because you were
there but when we when when we started
talking about trying to find a place to
go
again um this place came up from various
searches and I found Brett on Facebook
a message and I I don't know that I
asked this directly but what it
basically turned into was like can we
meet for coffee so that I can more or
less Vibe check the
place um like just kind of see what's
going on here so I showed up with like
five gospel tracks I was I was ready to
yeah you old school chick tracks too oh
yeah um yeah no it was it was good and I
think it was clear then that like this
is a place that we could could go um but
I think it's just made a big difference
not to
feel more or less homeless like we did
for a
decade um living in rock wall
is you don't find that many like-minded
people um and it can feel isolating and
it can even though like you know just
demographically and socially we're we're
not in a position like being worried for
ourselves but like it's also just it's
just a drag not to feel like anybody
around you feels the same way as you do
about so many things even even just the
way you approach the
world um
so that I think has been the biggest the
biggest
difference well it's a joy a joy having
youall be apart and yeah we're grateful
grateful for your presence thanks can
youall give them a hand
[Applause]
all right next I'd like to invite my
friend let's see Marcy Clark y'all give
her a
[Applause]
hand
e
e e
it's just a fresh reminder you know that
uh the the work that you all are doing
here really matters the way we relate to
people you know I I send out if you're
in our rotation of volunteers I'll send
out a little a little text you know in
the afternoon and we'll often mention
hey remember there's folks coming
through those doors for the first time
you never know what they're caring you
never know what they're going through
you know and uh I really I just I want
to encourage us to continue to be that
safe space for people on their Journeys
um whether it's like the Fishers coming
out of you know kind of on their own
Journey with religion and church and you
know doing a Vibe check on who what's up
here you know or it's Marcy coming out
of of her own um you know a violent past
and like just he's yeah it it matters
the the work and the love of God through
all of you it's it's yeah a privilege to
to partner with you in it so um so
tonight we're going to close out as we
always do with um communion and just a
chance to um kind of reenter on Christ
since uh Christ is the the very
Foundation of this community you know it
is we are all about love and connection
and relationship and being there for one
another but it's not only that but
underneath that underg guarding it is
the very love of the god we've come to
know in Jesus Christ so uh I just
encourage you uh as you participate
tonight as we come forward uh to have
that that open heart to whatever maybe
Christ wants to to speak to you connect
with you so um as we uh well let me
explain kind of the way we'll do this if
you're new so we'll just go kind of r
row by row and we'll just form one line
right here in the middle um we practice
what's called an Open Table meaning if
you're here tonight and you want to
participate then you're free to do that
regardless of your exact beliefs or you
know denominational affiliation uh you
should know the red is wine the white is
uh is grape juice so this is the
table not of the
church but of the Lord and it's made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him more so
come you who have much
faith and you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here
long you who have tried to
follow and you who feel like you
failed come come because it's the Lord
Jesus himself who invites you and it's
his will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the table
[Music]
you guys can feel welcome to stand with
us and sing this last song if you want
or sit and receive it whatever your
preference
is I love you
Lord for your mercy never
fails all my
days I've been in your
from the moment that I wake
up until I lay my
head I will sing of the
good sing that again
[Music]
together I love you
Lord for your mercy never fails me
all my
days I've been held in your
hand from the moment that I wake
up until I lay my
head I will see of the
goodness of
God all my
life oh my life you have been Sav
and all my life you have been so so
good with every breath that I am
a I will
speak of the
goodness of God I love your voice I love
your
voice you have led me through the fire
high in darkest
nights you are close like no
other I know you as a
father I've known you as a
friend and I have Liv in the
goodness of
God and all my life you have been f
oh my life you have been so
good with every breath that I
enable I will
seeing of the goodness of
God I will
see of the goodness of God
your goodness is running after it's
running after
me your goodness is running after it's
running after me with my life laid down
I Surrender now I give you
everything your goodness is running out
it's running out after me's sing that
again your good is running after running
after
[Music]
me your goodness is running after
running after me with my life laid down
I Surrender now I give you
everything your goodness is running out
running out
[Music]
it's running after
me my life you have been
Faith all my life you have been so so
good
with every breath that I
am I will
see of the
goodness of
[Music]
God I will
see of the
good of God
[Music]
thank you so much for joining us this
evening if you are new we would love for
you to fill out a card at the table on
your way out or uh scan the qard on the
screen and you can fill one out online
if that's better for you um take a
moment to remind you about meetups um we
can all use more relational support and
spiritual connection I think we heard
that tonight um the way we do that at
the table is through Meetup so if you're
not a part of a Meetup please use the QR
code find a Meetup there are lots of
them there's um there spread out there's
one in nadaa there's one in um Allen
there's one here in Wy there different
times so there's a way to connect so
please uh reach out and get a Vibe check
from Brett on the website
um giving generosity is a key aspect of
life of adoration and worship if the
table is your church home then we invite
you to scan the QR code uh give
financially or visit the table tx.org
and finally you're going to have to give
me a minute
[Music]
tonight let's send you into this week
with a blessing so if you can hold your
hands out if receiving posture or just
um open your heart to these
words you are a child of
God you are a child of
God this is true in your best day and it
is true in your worst
day so as you go into your week ahead
with his yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in between go fill
with the assurance that you are
loved you are worthy and you are
accepted just as you
are go filled with God's word the Holy
Spirit and desire to extend these same
Gifts of Grace and unconditional love to
everyone you come in contact
with be blessed we'll see you next
Sunday and at the chili cook off um if
you need a hug feel free to come see
[Music]
me your goodness is running
after running after
me your good is running after running
after laid down I Surrender now I give
you
everything your goodness is running out
running after after me
[Music]
thanks bro
I
[Music]